-Guys, today's the day
that is all about giving thanks,
so I thought,
what better day to write up
my weekly thank you notes?
Do you guys mind?
Is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some
thank you note-writing
music, please?
[ Gentle melody playing ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade,
for being the worst time
for the edibles to kick in.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Slow-mo ] Spongebob.
-Thank you,
Thanksgiving leftovers,
for also being a sly way
to steal someone's Tupperware.
[ Laughter ]
"I'll return it."
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
electric carving knife,
for making it sound like
my turkey has
a personal massager.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzing sound ]
-Ew. Ew. Wow.
I just got that one.
-I'm not sure if I did.
-Oh, my God.
-Thank you, playing
a board game with family
after Thanksgiving dinner,
for being a fun way to say,
"I don't think
we've fought enough yet."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
inflatable yard decorations,
for letting my neighbors
celebrate the holidays
with a 24/7 leaf blower.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank you notes!